this is one of the things that  distinguished communism from nazism  let's say and made it even maybe more  pernicious  the nazis basically said the world  that's for the aryans and the rest of  you can go to hell and we'll be happy to  aid in the  flames let's say there's not a  universalism associated with that  there's a definite exclusion and it's  pretty bloody obvious on the communist  front though and this is maybe what made  it such a powerful substitute in some  sense for for christianity there was the  notion that what we were working for was  the universal brotherhood of man and  this intense inclusiveness where  everyone could live together peacefully  and so people were also led down the  garden path by that presumption and  found out that lying in the service of  future utopia turns out to be a pathway  to hell just like lying in the service  of an exclusionary fascist state